mais d'abord la ville de tour annonce
que de nouvelles places de parking vont
devenir payantes et oui on vous le
disait il y a un instant 307 places de
stationnement s'ajouteront au 3600 déjà
payantes la mise en place sera effective
à compter du 26 février prochain et
concerne une dizaine de rus et de
quartiers comme l'avenue de la tranchée
le quartier cololbert notamment la rue
du CNE ou le boulevard beréranger et les
usagers vous allez le voir sont assez
partagé sur le
sujet 300 places gratuites dans le
centre-ville vont devenir payant nous en
pensez quoi arrive à un moment on pourra
même plus se garer du tout c'est de la
connerie c'est un moment on pourra même
plus se garer là moi même pour
travailler je suis obligé de payer en
face c'est une manière aussi de nous
faire de nous empêcher de venir avec les
véhicules en ville comme ça avec leur
projet là écologique là donc voilà tout
simplement et après ils vont passer au
vignettes critère je sais pas quoi et
puis après les voites des pauvres il
pouront plus un train ville et puis
après ce sera réservé au riches en tant
commerçant je trouve je trouve c'est un
petit peu dommage dans le sens où va
avoir un peu moins de passage en
centreville je pense étant donné que les
places deviennent payantes ça représente
un gros avantage je pense pour les
centres commerciaux pour les résidents
c'est une chose mais pour les gens de
passage voilà c'est le nouveau monde
c'est comme ça il y aura bientôt plus de
voiture donc on sera tous dans des
navettes et c'est tant mieux donc il
faut qu'on apprenne après que les pour
les résidents effectivement c'est galère
la Marie quant àelle explique ce choix
par la volonté de lutter contre le
stationnement prolongé de certains
véhicules les fameux véhicules ventouses
un phénomène qui gênerait l'accès au
commerce mais qui en dit après également
les riverins écoutez Christophe
boulanger conseiller municipal de la
ville de tour on s'est aperçu dans cette
étude que on avait des stationnements en
souterrain qui étaient sous-utilisé et
et très largement sous-utilisé he
puisquon a des taux d'occupation qui qui
sont inférieurs à 70 %. alors que c'est
des ouvrages qui ont coûté extrêmement
cher aux collectivités et puis on a un
besoin de de reconquérir l'espace public
euh pour pour partager cet espace public
entre les différents modes de de
déplacement que ça soit pour les piétons
pour les cyclistes ou ou autres et et
donc l'un des enjeux c'est effectivement
de s'assurer que ne stationne en surface
que les gens qui ont besoin d'y
stationner et ça passe par la
rationalisation de de de de l'usage le
stationnement payant n une seule
fonction c'est celle de permettre la
rotation pour que les gens qui ont
besoin de venir stationner en ville pour
un rendez-vous médical ou pour faire des
courses puisse le puisse le faire et
donc il faut limiter les voitures
ventous euh et donc c'est ce qu'on
détecte sur sur ce secteur qui
aujourd'hui ne sont pas payants à
l'intérieur de
zones